hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to the last
video game I've ever played all the way
through with Super Mario Brothers week
and before that it was metroid prime 2
on the Gamecube that's an entire system
later that's not to say I don't dabble
in a little Mario card Marvel vs. Capcom
3 or at my most embarrassing recording
myself playing the Michael Jackson
experience in my pajamas which you are
not going to see I bring this up to give
you some idea of where I'm coming from
that I did play a lot of video games
growing up but recently I've kind of
fallen out of touch and that I still try
to keep a little on top of things by
being a casual gamer here and there I
bring this up because it's important to
know my background when I ask a question
that's been circulating the past few
years our video games aren't now on the
one hand this is a stupid question as
you could easily say of course it's art
practically anything can be art just
look at the definition the expression or
application of human creative skill and
imagination typically in a visual form
such as painting or sculpture or works
produced by such skill and imagination
so he'll even the picture you did have a
horsey when you were 5 years old
technically counts as aren't but I think
what people really mean when they ask
this question is our video games hi art
will they be remembered are they
timeless do they say something relevant
about life or humanity that will be
relevant years later that's what people
are really trying to get down to I must
admit I didn't really think too hard
about this subject matter until they
played the game Metroid other app
despite all the hype being built around
it the game pissed off a great number of
fans and gamers but not for the same
reasons that it would have 20 years ago
the biggest complaint was that samus the
badass bounty hunter and starve one of
them tendo's biggest franchises has now
been reduced to an overly emotional
yapping drama-queen with dialogue more
like a soap opera that has faced opera
to say fans were pissed was an
understatement
but when it came down to the actual
gameplay itself people didn't seem to
have that big a problem with it of
course some people didn't enjoy the
plane part but the focus of the
criticisms was how poorly they
represented the character and the
when did this happen nobody used to
question the motivations of a plumber
going after a princess or the storyline
of two guys with guns stopping an alien
invasion
but clearly much more is expecting out
of video games because the medium itself
has naturally evolved but many critics
out there still declare that's just a
modern updated version of this in my
opinion the best way to understand the
evolution of the craft is by comparing
it to another craft that many people
argued for years was an art movies for a
long time many art critics declared film
as just a means of escape and
entertainment and nothing else but as
the art form advanced more and more we
saw filmmakers take chances by
challenging audiences with new ways of
telling stories and expressing ideas
films could be disturbing
thought-provoking enlightening even
breaking the bonds of the three-act
structure and just expressing motion
dreams or the subconscious because of
this it is very hard nowadays to find
people who don't in some form or another
see the possibility of filmmaking great
art
regardless the question remains do video
games have the same capacity well many
would argue nowadays that video games
are just a cheap imitation of movies
that they're trying to cash in on a lot
of the unique elements of film without
actually making a film and in many
respects they're correct there's no
doubt movies make big money and the more
game makers can make their games look
similar to movies the more people will
get the impression that they're actually
playing a movie which is a very
attractive idea seeing how people are
attracted to movies already so does that
mean video games are just these light
are they just advanced versions of
dragon's lair where footage tells you
where to go and if you don't follow you
just lose a turn there's no denying that
some if not many games are very much
like that so how can games be expected
to evolve as an artform if it's just a
watered down version of another art form
well games do have a very distinct
difference over movies music paintings
other forms of art and that difference
is choice for the most part you can't
decide where a movie a book or a piece
of music goes it's finished when it's
finished and you observe it from there
but video games by design are dependent
on different outcomes and true there are
some pieces of art and literature where
the choice of the observer plays a big
part but in videogames that's not just a
small part of the process it's the
majority of the focus because of this we
create a medium where not only are they
allowed to experiment with choice but
they're actually expected to and when
you're expected to produce more
possibilities you're expected to
experiment more take risks more and
generally find out how many outcomes can
be created sure most of them are very
simple as in avoid getting hit by
something or you'll die but how about
the games that create new worlds to
explore new stories to create and not
just from the Creator anymore but from
the observer few would disagree that
much of art is about the creation and
this is one of the rare mediums that
allows the viewer to make just as much
great art as the artist who created it
does it isn't just the graphics and the
technology that's evolving it's the
unique interaction between the player
and the game
and yes there are games that try to
serve as nothing but mindless
entertainment and there are games that
tried to be complex and interesting but
instead come out as predictable and
boring but how is that any different
from bad art or bad movies they're all
trying to tap into something that makes
you understand or celebrate the human
condition even something like
transformers yeah I know easy target but
nonetheless something as simple as
transformers is trying to get across
what we value as good human ethics right
down to the very basic good versus evil
now does that make it something that's
going to be relevant and studied years
later probably not but at the same time
you don't call an entire artistic medium
a failure because some bad art is
popular now the question is have
videogames reach that level of high art
that's a little bit more debatable as a
casual gamer
I don't know if I've seen that landmark
that's the game equivalent of the
Seventh Seal or 2001 but I would make
the argument that some have come close
this may sound strange but something
like the sins as much as I personally
don't like playing it tools with the
idea of living your life in a world
almost identical to ours but once again
the choices you make in the environment
I think can say much about how people
live their lives in the real world and
in their fantasy world just the
experience in what you do and how you
play and how it contrasts to how you
react in the real world that's a very
different and interesting form of
artistic expression whether you realize
you're doing it or not and again the
genuine art comes from the user
not necessarily the Creator I think the
same can be said for games like Skyrim
or World of Warcraft or any of these
games where you're allowed not to just
go on adventures but live a life any way
you want to live it in a completely
different reality I think it could also
make the argument that games like
BioShock Infinite they're not allowing
as much choice as other games for you'd
some very powerful commentary while also
being a visual Marvel but like I said as
a casual gamer I can't act like I'm the
biggest expert on the subject maybe that
big game changer is out there and I just
haven't seen it yet maybe it just hasn't
gotten the public attention that it
deserves or maybe the big game changer
is one of these games and the reveal
time will slowly show that but what I do
know is the possibilities are there and
they're being experimented with day
after day as the medium continues to
grow it reminds me of when people used
to say that comic books weren't high art
and that they were nothing but childish
nonsense Alamut I used to kind of be on
that boat too
but then groundbreaking works like Mouse
came out and Watchmen and Persepolis and
a lot of other great works that said hey
we don't care what you think we're going
to prove that there is a medium here
that can be as powerful thoughtful
provoking and emotionally stimulating as
any other great work of art and sure
enough the medium is much more respected
now than it was before an argument has
even risen that comic book heroes are
the new Greek myths being written from
so many different points of view but
still being the center of value that
popular culture looks up to
perhaps the reimagining of videogame
characters with their legends and quests
could be working its way up to the same
page so in answer to our videogames art
or high art I will make the argument
that if people don't see that the answer
is yes they will if a game doesn't exist
that'll sway you over the possibilities
that continue to evolve with technology
inevitably have to and yes many great
people I admire like Roger Ebert
declared they never have been and never
will be art and while I respectfully
disagree I don't see him or anyone who
thinks similar any less intelligent or
influential I simply ask that people who
think it cannot evolve at the very least
keep their minds open to the roads that
can be traveled with the medium that if
you think video games are not high art
now be aware that they certainly have
the ability to be so in the future many
evolving artists and mediums have been
shunned in the past and much of their
progress came from not what they weren't
but what they could be and it's hard to
see how the evolution of this to this is
any different from the evolution of this
to this yes there will always be
mindless games for escapism in the same
way there will always be mindless movies
for escapism but if that is the full
extent of the possibilities you can see
in video games I humbly challenge you to
stop start over and play again how then
is Dasha Critic I remember it so you
don't have to and speaking of mindless
escapes
yeah you've branded
well we got a lot of people asking hey
where's suburban nights and kick-ass II
on DVD well now's your chance to
preorder the reorder once again that's
right shipping will begin July 1st and
on top of that we have copies left of
the nostalgia critic reloaded DVD and
the order in the next two weeks I will
personally sign them for you but hell
with that would you like to know the
DVDs you're buying are going to a good
cause well they are we're gonna use that
money to help fund our charity drive
this summer the charity is for the one
step at a time camp and you can help
support us to make this charity drive
happen buying great entertainment going
to a great cause what's not to like well
okay you don't have to like these but
there's not a part of